welcome back so we're talking about
machine learning models from data and I
want to talk a little bit about where
neural networks and artificial
intelligence fit into this because
there's all of these different kind of
words and phrases for for machine
learning so again the neural networks
are super important we use them all the
time they're a lot of the technology
that is used in your daily life like
Alexa or Siri or Google Images and
Facebook they are built on kind of
neural network architectures for for
their their technology but I do want to
emphasize that neural networks are
really kind of a subset not an equal
subset but really a subset of machine
learning ok so they're an important part
of the larger family of machine learning
the other thing I want to talk about is
artificial intelligence so you'll hear
this all the time now artificial
intelligence AI and I think this is very
fuzzy kind of murky so machine learning
is pretty well defined nowadays neural
networks
you know we I'll give you a few lectures
in a series on what neural networks are
I can explain what they are to you
artificial intelligence is a little bit
more nebulous I mean generally speaking
it's this this idea that what we want is
a collection of algorithms and
experience and data an expert system
that can ask its own questions gather
its own data decide on the architecture
for learning really do some of the
things that biological systems can do so
you know a cat and a dog or
fundamentally curious and they go and
explore and they learn on their own and
they have a framework but it's kind of
an overarching framework where they can
you know learn how to learn better over
time and so that's very cool and there's
lots of interesting applications of
artificial intelligence and it hopes I
think to get towards some of these
aspects of more generalizability or you
know
if more higher hierarchies of models and
models of models and things like that
but I also want to point out that at
least in well I think in lots of fields
and in popular and technical fields
there's what I'll call a lot of
ballooning statements a lot of
ballooning statements about about AI so
people are using this word this buzzword
to be a catch-all for everything they're
gonna do to solve world hunger and you
know everything in the world is gonna be
solved because of artificial
intelligence and I think there's a lot
of ballooning statements these kind of
ballooned statements that people make
about how big artificial intelligence is
and how close we are and what the
capabilities are and I'll just give you
some examples you know or some some
anecdotes so most machine learning
algorithms that we're talking about most
of these these architectures where you
can build models from data they have
parameters hyper parameters that you
have to tune how fast you train them how
many degrees of freedom things like that
there's hyper parameters in a neural
network how many layers and how many
nodes and there is still kind of this
overarching process when you train these
models of turning those hyper parameters
until until they work better okay and
usually that is a human guided process
an expert human changes the architecture
and tweaks those hyper parameters and I
mean there are certainly efforts to
autumn to make that automatic and to
have kind of a meta learning theory
where you can have machines teaching
other machines based on what they've
learned so this is happening but I will
be honest in my estimation or at least
where we are right now there's still a
huge gap between kind of the human
guided expertise and
even remotely what we can do in
artificial intelligence okay so I don't
want to be too pessimistic pessimistic I
think there is a tremendous amount of
potential for expert systems for systems
that can learn to learn and that can
explain themselves and that can go be
curious and gather new data to answer
questions I think that is a very noble
and interesting research effort but we
are there really there's a chasm between
where we're at now in that goal that
doesn't mean we should work towards it
but I really do think you should be
cautious of what I'm going to call
ballooning statements people that that
overinflate kind of what they're doing
by just using a buzzword that sounds
really really cool okay I mean I don't
know I've heard commercials of exercise
machines that are going to use
artificial intelligence to tailor your
workout that sounds like a ballooning
statement to me I mean I think they are
probably doing cool machine learning and
optimizing models from data with
regression and maybe they cluster or
classify people and you know stuff like
that but I I would say that's probably a
far cry from from artificial
intelligence okay so the theory of
learning the theory of intelligent
systems how does one question and and
gather data to answer questions I mean
that is very interesting but let's not
forget most biological all biological
learning systems that we know of birds
and and humans and dogs and cats they
are not just fed information they have
bodies and they live in the world and
they go explore and they gather
information they live in groups where
the information is passed down and there
is feedback there's feedback at so many
levels between the world and the learner
in biological systems and I think if
we're ever gonna get to real artificial
intelligence we're gonna have to build
in those aspects so I think a lot of the
best work is in robotics for example
because those robotic systems actually
can be curious and they can actually go
and explore the world and they have kind
of bodies that they can go and get that
feedback so I think there is real great
work here but just be on the lookout for
learning statements okay thank you